bonjour monsieur je vous donne la liste
des produits dont vous pouvez acheter
chez nous comme chaque jeudi
janick est à l'accueil de balises qui
depuis trois ans est bénévole explique
aux bénéficiaires leurs droits et
surtout prête une oreille attentive
on en profite pour aborder avec eux nous
l'avons problèmes et les écouter c'est
de voir ce qu'on peut
comment on peut faire pour les aider il
ya un énorme besoin d' écoutes chez les
gens qu'on accueille ils ont besoin de
parler de leurs problèmes qui nous on va
pas leur trouver des solutions mais rate
c'est évident mais le fait d'en parler
pour chats pendant fait du bien 38
bénévoles se relaient pour accueillir
les 55 familles familles monoparentales
chômage ou baisse de revenus et les
bénéficiaires peuvent venir sur une
durée de trois à quatre mois
ils sont adressés par les services
sociaux de quatre communes
saint-quentinoise
en général quand elles viennent chez
nous c'est pas la première nécessité ces
familles qui ont un projet qu'il est et
en venant ici ça leur permet de je
dirais de réaliser ce projet avec
l'ambition de s'en sortir alors sortir
de l'eau mais en les responsabilisant
sur leurs achats
et quand ils viennent chez nous ils ont
des montants d'achat qui leur sont
alloués on essaye de s'adapter à la
situation globale familiale
de la famille des conditions de vie des
conditions de recherche d'emploi les
enfants c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
paramètres qui peuvent entrer en ligne
de compte des produits d'entretien
alimentaires ou d'hygiène balises qui
propose environ 300 références à prix
réduit un panier de 60 euros dans le
commerce vaut une trentaine d'euros
dans cette boutique on va les acheter
autrement dans certains magasins on est
livré par d'autres on a d'autres qui
viennent par revivre et éventuellement
des collectes puisqu'il nous arrive de
temps en temps de faire des fadettes
également chaque mois une commission
étudie les dossiers des demandeurs
l'association existe depuis maintenant
24 ans financé par les communes saint
quentin en yvelines le département et
des dons son budget est de 210 mille
euros